[Music]
on this Saturday night buried in snow
the historic and deadly snowstorm
blanketing Buffalo you got this giant
mound of snow behind you what do we got
here that's my car the race to dig out
before another heavy dump this is winter
this is it for us you know plus the
thick wall of snow blowing over our
border
on the west coast the complete opposite
British Columbia has been in Canada has
felt like Ground Zero for climate change
cop 27 creeps into overtime we cannot
believe by having abandoned the
possibility of keeping 1.5 degrees
Celsius alive the sticking points
preventing a goal being kicked at the
climate Summit and offside already today
I feel disabled today I feel
a migrant worker the bizarre comments by
the boss of FIFA
global national with Farah Nasser
good evening thank you for joining us
quite the scene in Western New York
State residents digging out after more
than a meter and a half of snow blanket
of the region the past 24 hours has been
difficult but it's also been dangerous
at least two deaths are being connected
to the storm heart attacks from
shoveling snow as Jennifer Johnson
reports in our top story tonight with
more flurries on the way it's possible
the storm could be one for the record
books
it looked like a scene out of a sci-fi
movie Drone footage showing a wall of
snow rolling into Buffalo Western New
York state is being slammed by an
historic snowstorm that has closed roads
triggered driving bans and left
thousands stranded local residents no
strangers to big storms say they've
never seen anything like this when you
see that wall of snow it's insane it's
Indescribable the storm has broken a New
York record for the most snowfall in a
24-hour period so much snow that
Sunday's Buffalo Bills football game
against the Cleveland Browns has had to
be moved to Detroit the Stadium's Green
Turf is Now hidden under a heavy blanket
of white the snow is so heavy I'm you
know I got it you know I got a heavy
duty plow and I'm having a hard time 11
New York counties are under a state of
emergency
jackknifed tractor-trailer trucks have
shut down highways everywhere you look
cars and motorists are stranded I was
stuck in the intersection for about a
solid 30 45 minutes and trying to rock
the car out luckily the cops came and
they gave me a push that was thousands
of people have lost power as the
temperatures plummet in the Buffalo area
but officials are begging people to stay
home if they can some of the worst
conditions that our public works
department and sheriff's deputies have
ever faced Crews at Buffalo's
International Airport are working around
the clock moving the heavy snow to keep
runways clear but hundreds of flights
have been canceled or delayed from
Detroit to New York especially difficult
on this busy travel weekend ahead of
Thanksgiving you pray you make it you
have to have buffers a buffer there and
a buffer back about 6 million Americans
from upper Michigan to New York have
been under snow alerts many blame global
warming for heating up the Great Lakes
causing the air above to hold more
moisture and produce more snow just
shelter in place and we'll get through
this together unfortunately this
Relentless Wallop isn't ending soon more
snow is in the forecast for Sunday and
early next week an already
record-breaking storm poised to break
even more records Jennifer Johnson
Global News Washington
let's go straight to Global's chief
meteorologist Anthony Farnell who is now
in Niagara Falls but Anthony you spent
yesterday and this morning in Buffalo
what was it like
oh it's just incredible to see a couple
of things how fast the cleanup is
underway there are truckloads of snow
being removed from that City every
minute it seems like but earlier we were
in one of the hardest hit areas around
Orchard Park that's south of Buffalo
where an incredible
195 centimeters of snow fell that was
enough to completely buried cars
incredible drifts coming off of the
roofs of houses and also playgrounds
that don't look like playgrounds anymore
there was a fence around one that was
about four feet high and you could
barely see it so that's just a sign of
how much snow is there and as far as
getting here to Niagara Falls it wasn't
easy one of the major highways
Interstate 90 remained closed throughout
the day there were transport trucks
lining the side streets waiting for that
to open Farah
all right and and what's happening on
our side of the Border Where You Are
well it's snowing here in Niagara Falls
we're tracking this same snow squall
it's actually teamed up with a Lake
Ontario snow squall and bringing near
zero visibility they're expecting
another 15 to about 30 centimeters of
snow in this area starting in the next
hour or two so it's not done yet
tomorrow the winds shift and that could
bring more snow to areas like the North
End of Toronto that hasn't really seen
it as of yet Farah
well we are getting closer to Winter
Anthony Farnell thanks so much have a
safe drive home
trying to avert more unprecedented
weather was also at the center of the
cop 27 climate Summit in Egypt it was
supposed to end on Friday but it's now
gone into overtime right now it's the
middle of the night in charmele shake
and negotiations are still going on with
no new agreement to tackle the climate
crisis and to compensate the smaller
Nations bearing the brunt of it though
as Mike droulet reports that hasn't
stopped potential solutions from being
met with intense skepticism
moments after throwing flour on an Andy
Warhol painted car in Italy climate
activists were dragged away an absurd
act they called it for an increasingly
absurd climate crisis far away at cop 27
in Egypt a climate deal that looked like
a long shot a day ago look forward to
good news now seems Within Reach or at
least part of it for the first time
there was agreement to create a loss and
damage fund which would cover climate
change damages incurred by poorer
countries such as those in Africa
devastated by drought and famine we need
to stop when disasters happen we need to
stop clearly just sending thoughts and
prayers to people facing devastation
and this is one way uh that actually
signals that this process is listening
to those folks uh all over the world but
key questions remain unanswered which
countries and industries will pay for it
and how much those details will be
decided over the next year the other big
issue on the table was the cop 26 goal
of reducing emissions in hopes of
keeping global warming under 1.5 degrees
Celsius for us and many others there
can't be any backsliding on 1.5 degrees
Celsius we cannot leave charmel Sheikh
by having abandoned the possibility of
keeping 1.5 degrees Celsius alive that
goal could be harder to reach only 30
countries improve their climate plan
since last year's Summit Canada for one
has made promises but it's unclear how
they'll be met and scientists say that
has to change because to remain under
the 1.5 degree limit Global emissions
would need to be cut 43 percent by 2030
but but at our current Pace they'll dip
less than one percent by then we have to
be honest Agape is uh really huge and it
is huge because we continue to rely on
Pathways that are fossil fuel dependent
that is a reality world leaders he says
need to commit to change time is running
out microlyte Global News Toronto
weeks into November much of Canada is
already seeing its fair share of wintry
conditions yet in British Columbia a
severe lack of rainfall continues to
take a toll on the west coast in the
Fraser Valley east of Vancouver homes
were even put on evacuation alert this
week over a wildfire and as Nita Garcia
explains experts warn the severity of
droughts isn't just defined by less rain
but also human actions magnifying the
climate crisis
the place dubbed as Canada's wet Coast
faces compounding consequences of a
months-long drought
of emergency was extended to this month
in the dried out Sunshine Coast and much
of the Lower Mainland has been under
extreme drought conditions as well
allowing a wildfire believed to be
human-caused to take hold and force
evacuation alerts near Agassi about 100
kilometers east of Vancouver it's not
safe to put fire Crews on the ground on
the hillside a number of trees are
blowing down in the wind and then of
course they're shooting down a hill
similar to a torpedo
the drought hit and the creek was dry
while salmon hatcheries like this one in
Metro Vancouver are seeing more dead
fish than live fish we could lose a
whole season of chum here another
species of salmon Coho are being pulled
from the creek to have their eggs
harvested the water has disappeared in
the large part and the fish that are in
the creek
have nowhere to go they can't spawn it's
not clear whether the salmon decline is
due to the drought experts say BC has
historically seen similar droughts but
worn human cause pressures will lead to
even more frequent and extreme weather
events fueled by the climate crisis with
the human impacts of warmer temperatures
land use change
um the severity of these droughts are
going to be worse British Columbia has
been in Canada has felt like Ground Zero
for climate change in the past couple
years right we've made a devastating
Heat Wave last year followed by the
fires which were Then followed by the
floods the sort of series of compound
events this Canadian climate scientist
was a delegate at the UN climate change
conference in Egypt what really matters
is when this meeting's done what happens
when all these delegates and government
Representatives go home ongoing over
consumption and inadequate Resource
Management are among the biggest
contributors experts say worsen the
effects of the climate crisis we need to
be telling the government what we want
it to do at the municipal level
provincial level and definitely at the
federal level uh to see action on
climate change meaning we can expect
more dismal conditions like this unless
more is done sooner
Global News
Ukraine's Deputy Prime Minister sits
down with global news
coming up her country's request to
Canada
plus lgbtq plus fans boycotting the
World Cup in Qatar
[Music]
Canada's prime minister is on the home
stretch of his 10-day Foreign Tour today
Justin Trudeau touched down in Tunisia
for the francophone Summit the final
stop he's there to form closer ties with
members as Russia's invasion of Ukraine
sends food prices soaring across Africa
but a key domestic issue played an
important role in his first one-on-one
meeting Mackenzie gray has more from
gerba Mackenzie
far the prime minister's made his final
stop on his 10-day Around the World trip
in German Tunisia for La francophony an
excited French president Emmanuel macron
greeted Justin Trudeau the two leaders
put up the vast majority of the funds
for this organization dedicated to the
promotion of the French language
but it's the deteriorating situation in
Haiti that's also a major concern for
member states tomorrow Canada is set to
host a meeting of 13 other countries on
the topic today foreign affairs minister
Melanie Jolie announced sanctions
against three new Haitians everybody
recognizes that there's an issue
happening in Haiti and that we need to
step up our game and do more so that's
our job
the Prime Minister also carved out time
to touch on a major to domestic issue
discussing Health Care in a sit-down
with Quebec Premier Francois Lugo the
federal government had unsuccessful
negotiations with the provinces earlier
this month to increase the Canada Health
transfer in response the Liberals have
now signaled they're willing to do
bilateral deals with each province
the host of The Summit Tunisian
president kais Saeed has frequently been
condemned by Canada for recently
granting himself sweeping new powers
Saeed sacked the Tunisian prime minister
dissolved Parliament and his jail
journalists
these concerns prompted Ottawa to push
for La francophone need to be postponed
Quebec pondered a boycott but both ended
up attending using the opportunity to
raise human rights and Democratic
concerns member countries are expected
to re-elect the current Secretary
General and vote to have Paris host the
2024 Gathering Trudeau will fly back to
Ottawa tomorrow night ending one of the
longest trips he's had as prime minister
Farah
thanks Mackenzie that's Mackenzie gray
in Tunisia
he warned Ukraine is in the crosshairs
at this year's International Security
Forum being held in Halifax Ukrainian
president vlodimir zielinski told
officials gathering at the summit he
wants Canada's help spearheading a
long-term peace plan to end the war for
good
honest peace can only be the result of
the complete demolition of Russian
aggression and I am asking you to help
us implement this formula this is the
only way to the real peace
zilinski made the comments in a
pre-recorded video to kick off the Forum
in Halifax he listed 10 critical steps
to achieve real peace including the
full-scale withdrawal of Russian forces
ensuring the country's food and energy
security and Ukraine's territorial
integrity
and Ukraine's Deputy Prime Minister is
on the ground in Halifax for that
security forum and she spoke with our
Mercedes Stevenson
we got used to to live in darkness
both both have been affected severely by
by multiple crimes committed against
people but also the first thing I
noticed when I landed to Montreal is
that there's so much light around you
this is not what we have but I think
that the what is more important is the
spirit this is the spirit which cannot
be undermined by any measures of
demoralization Russia tries to put on
Ukraine whether it's destroying critical
infrastructure attacking residential
buildings massive torturing of
population in the occupied areas or any
failure on a battlefield which forces
them to use the hybrid Warfare as the
major method of their of their
aggression so I think that the major
spirit in Ukraine is that there's no way
to surrender there's only way to Victory
and this leads to a permanent failure of
Russian Federation all although of
course the suffering and the losses
among population are really really
serious
and you can see the full interview with
Mercedes Stevenson and the Ukrainian
Deputy Prime Minister tomorrow on the
west block right here on global
[Music]
I had the World Cup that's anything but
normal cut their 2022 kicks off in a
cloud of criticism
[Music]
Alfonso Davies and the Canada men's
soccer team is now in Qatar gearing up
for what could be the biggest Tournament
of their lives as fans and athletes from
around the world brace for the FIFA
World Cup that is kicking off tomorrow
but for many others it is hard to get
excited because if the controversial
host country Qatar has a poor human
rights record notably over the treatment
of immigrant workers leading up to the
tournament yet today FIFA's president
tried to deflect criticism he says he
understands discrimination equating it
to how he was bullied in school for his
freckles and attacks what he calls
hypocrisy from Western Nations
I think for what we Europeans have been
doing in the last 3000 years
around the world we should be
apologizing for next 3000 years
before starting to give moral lessons
treatment of the lgbtq plus Community
has also drawn concerns and criticism as
Redmond Shannon reports human rights
Advocates say the country's law and
homosexuality make it an unsafe place
for fans to visit
the biggest single sport event in the
world is almost here are we just excited
to be here because it's first time to us
to see the trophy cutter is a tiny
country very wealthy from natural gas
but with a poor human rights record
migrant workers toiled in brutal heat to
build stadiums The Guardian newspaper
estimated more than 6 000 immigrant
workers from South Asia died over a
decade a number of qatars government
says is misleading but it doesn't shy
away from its policy on same-sex
relationships which are illegal and can
result in imprisonment one Qatari
tournament Ambassador recently called
homosexuality a damage in the mind
another man being paid handsomely as an
ambassador is David Beckham once
regarded as an icon in the gay community
I think it's important when you're a
visitor to a country that you respect
the culture of your house Nation
Britain's foreign secretary recently
Drew criticism for this advice England's
head coach says he won't be silencing
his players as FIFA has requested we
have always spoken about issues that we
think should be talked about
particularly the ones we feel we can
affect England's team captain will wear
this armband and the team flew to Doha
in a plane called rainbow other teams
say they'll make similar gestures I have
traditionally also watched it my whole
life every single one I've never missed
one but I just don't feel that it's
ethically right for me to watch it this
year Helen Kennedy is executive director
of LGBT plus advocacy Group igal Canada
she says rather than pushing for change
at a tournament human rights standards
should be a prerequisite of hosts it's
just a horrendous situation for queer
folks in these jurisdictions and so I
you know point the finger squarely in in
FIFA's direction that they need to take
accountability Canada Soccer says it
once improved inclusivity and Qatar to
be a legacy of the tournament Redmond
Shannon Global News London
[Music]
next I'm covering hidden galaxies meet
part of the team behind the James Webb
Telescope
NASA's James Webb Telescope is a game
changer the telescope that was developed
in partnership with the Canadian space
agency is uncovering hidden secrets of
the universe but without the help of
science visual developers we would not
be able to see the images for their new
reality Marianne domain has been
exploring this new frontier Marianne
even if you're not a space buff it's
hard not to be impressed by the
spectacular images captured by the web
telescope the clarity and level of
detail are unprecedented and it takes
special skills to translate the science
into something we can view that's
because Webb is looking as far back as
13.5 billion years and revealing
galaxies as they looked around the time
when the Earth and Sun were formed web
sees infrared light something humans
aren't able to view so science visual
developers Joe depasquale and Elisa
pagon working out of the Space Telescope
Science Institute in Baltimore are
interpreting the data Webb is sending
back we can't see in the infrared so
there has to be some level of
translation here but we use physical
meaning like true physical science in
order to represent sort of the color and
it's the job of Lisa and I to take that
data to stretch it so that we can see
what's in the data and then we apply
Color according to those wavelengths and
so the the shortest wavelength filters
that we have we used blue for those and
as we move into longer and longer
wavelengths we go to Greens and then
Reds
launched on Christmas Day 2021 Webb is
far more powerful than its predecessor
the Hubble telescope this is The Pillars
of Creation as seen by Hubble in 1995
and now this is what Webb is showing us
what we're seeing when we look at these
images is the raw material for Life the
detail the clarity the color it all just
hit me all at once that yeah web is a
Next Generation Observatory it's going
to change astronomy forever as the
telescope travels through outer space it
will continue to reveal secrets of the
early Universe a world we could only
once imagine pharah back to you well it
makes you feel so insignificant that is
Miriam domain in Toronto thanks Marianne
and you can watch Marianne's full report
on the new reality tonight at 7 on
global and that's global national for
this Saturday night I'm Farah Nasser and
on behalf of our whole team here I want
to thank you so much for spending part
of your evening with us tonight's your
Canada is from another region slammed by
snow Fort Erie Ontario but the blister
and cold hasn't stopped this brave
surfer we love seeing your Canada so
please keep emailing us your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com
until we're together tomorrow take care
of yourselves and each other good night
[Music]
[Music]
thank you